salud en directo américa de france 24 y
nos acompaña claro que sí como todas las
mañanas más romeros a la mar bienvenida
a esta mañana de viernes y en salud
vamos a hablar de una muerte digna y
todo lo que significa más allá de la
eutanasia buenos días raúl así es es una
duda que nos surgió por ejemplo a raíz
de la noticia de sanlúcar el cineasta
francés que murió a través del suicidio
asistido y que pues al raíz de estos
debates vemos cómo se refleja eso que
dice de nuestra sociedad este tipo de
debates que tenemos alrededor de la
muerte no cuando se habla de muerte
digna eso engloba muchos términos vamos
a dejarlos claro es una muerte digna se
refiere a todo esto todos esos derechos
que tienen que ver con que se pueda
decidir sobre cómo queremos morir tomar
decisiones sobre el último tiempo de
nuestras vidas pero se incluyen muchas
cosas por ejemplo el acceso a cuidados
paliativos también el poder de decidir
sobre si queremos recibir o no ciertos
tratamientos en esos últimos momentos y
luego la muerte médicamente asistida eso
sí es o bien el suicidio asistido o bien
la eutanasia en que se diferencian pues
entienda el médico en el caso del
suicidio asistido la persona ingiere
decide o acciona el mecanismo para tomar
las sustancias que van a poner fin a su
vida en el caso de la eutanasia es el
médico quien lo hace estos últimos
puntos de la med de la muerte
médicamente asistida por supuesto es el
que más debate genera y hay muy pocos
países donde eso sea legal por ejemplo
pues españa-colombia es el único en
américa latina que es el legal entonces
bueno en estos casos vemos que son los
78 países donde suicidio asistido o
eutanasia es legal todavía es un debate
que está muy vivo en nuestro mundo en
nuestra sociedad suena feo no es ese
asistido porque finalmente si una
persona que tiene una enfermedad muy
grave degenerativa y que está sufriendo
con su vida pues ahí la palabra suicidio
también es bastante fuerte no pero güey
eso es lo que es sí claro pero pues el
debate alrededor de la eutanasia y el
suicidio asistido es nuevo marc pues así
no digamos que por un lado obviamente la
vida que se alarga gracias a los nuevos
descubrimientos y avances médicos de las
últimas décadas ha puesto una nueva luz
en todos estos debates pero la verdad es
que no termina de ser una cosa nueva de
hecho entrevistamos a la gracia y la de
jacob que es doctora de medicina
paliativa y también forma parte de la
red de cuidados derechos y decisiones en
el final de la vida de argentina y nos
contaba una historia desde ese país
latinoamericano
existía
ancestralmente un personaje que se
llamaba el despertador
qué es un lindo nombre el despertador en
las provincias del norte era y en el que
se podía llamar cuando una persona
estaba enferma suficiente y no se
terminaba de móvil entonces era alguien
que fue entrenado desde niñito para
poder respirar es decir sacar las penas
de esperar sacar las penas muy buen
momento también para recordar que el
origen de la palabra eutanasia viene de
buena muerte significa el buen morir
pero además es que hay otro ejemplo este
señor que ven en sus pantallas desde el
abuelo de la reina que acaba de fallecer
que falleció esta semana es jorge quinto
y él en
1936 murió a raíz de una eutanasia su
médico de cabecera su médico personal le
administró una dosis de morfina de iu de
cocaína que puso fin a su vida cuando él
ya estaba pues postrado por una
enfermedad que lo mantenía prácticamente
en coma eso fue en un momento en que era
pues totalmente impensable en la al
menos en lo legal en reino unido- poder
acceder a una eutanasia y que al menos
pone sobre la mesa este debate de que al
fin esta práctica ha sido algo a lo que
las personas que han tenido dinero o
acceso a este tipo de recursos han
accedido pues claro de una forma
bastante recurrente mientras que ha sido
algo que las personas de otros tipos de
provenientes pues que provienen de otros
tipos de capas sociales no han podido
acceder lamentablemente como todo en
nuestro mundo y tommy lo mejor aquí la
diferencia en la salud pero hablemos
ahora de los dilemas y la oposición el
auto nacio marc claro es importante
también poner este debate sobre la mesa
para tener todo este tipo de cosas
claras por supuesto una de las
suposiciones de religiosa no se opone la
eutanasia de la idea al final de que
dios es quien da y quita la vida en su
debido momento entonces una gran parte
de la oposición a este tipo de debates
viene por allí otro dilema que hay es el
tema del día de mavi o ético alrededor
de la muerte no hablábamos de que el
suicidio hace apenas unas semanas algo
que se debe prevenir entonces a veces
pues hablar del suicidio asistido como
tú mismo
decías ayudar a alguien a poner fin a su
vida puede ser algo que nos genera una
serie de contradicciones además existe
una preocupación y es que los
determinantes sociales de las personas
influyen también hablamos de
desigualdades que puedan terminar
desfavoreciendo a personas desigualdades
de clase
de género que entonces empuje al final a
las personas que han tenido vidas menos
dignas también a acceder a este tipo de
puesto a poner fin a su vida de una
forma más fácil y que eso también se
refleje en esta forma de acceder al
suicidio sin embargo por ejemplo desde
colombia camilo jaramillo que es abogada
del deslave que haga acompañado algunos
de los casos de eutanasia aquí en el
país nos hablaba de que la realidad es
bien diferente
al menos aquí en colombia las personas
que tienen acceso a las ganancias al
sistema médicamente asistido son las
personas que acceden al mejor sistema de
salud son las personas en las ciudades
principales son las personas que tienen
una de psa son las personas que han sido
diagnosticadas que han sido tratadas no
entonces en ese sentido pues yo creo que
al menos aquí en colombia el cast lo que
proponen algunos sectores donde van a
ser las personas con menos ingresos
económicos o las personas que no tienen
acceso al sistema de salud las que
acceden a la muerte médicamente asistida
pues eso no es la realidad y marc ayudar
a morir a alguien además va en contra de
lo que nos dicen que se debe hacer en
cuanto a la medicina no diferente
también a las creencias en muchas
comunidades si estamos hablando al menos
de la medicina occidental o de la
medicina moderna que es y que todos
vivimos en nuestro día a día al menos en
estos lados del mundo y precisamente eso
nos hablaba también desde su propia
experiencia la doctora graciela jacob
esencialmente muchos
yo diría que una gran mayoría están en
contra de los procesos de asistir a la
muerte activamente la muerte de su
paciente
calcula que todos nosotros nos formamos
con
decidir a dónde no hacer daño
con el desiderátum de salvar la vida
casi a toda costa pero cuando todo esto
existía no existía el nivel de
visitación éxito ahora
también en camila nos hablaba de esta
reticencia que a veces existe en el
mundo médico escuchamos la dentro de la
cultura está la jerarquía donde el
médico es el que sabe qué es lo que le
conviene al paciente y el paciente
simplemente obedece ahí hay un tema
claramente complicado porque el médico
entiende la muerte como un fracaso pues
entonces hace todo lo posible por no
dejar morir a la persona bien y en esta
misma línea el hecho de que el paciente
decida cuándo morir
pues revierte la relación
jerárquica que hay allí
claro raúl entendemos que los juramentos
hipocráticos que presiones del que toman
los médicos y que reflejan ese
pensamiento de la medicina occidental
porque nacía hipócrates fue uno de los
primeros médicos griegos y ya allí se
dice que nunca se va a poner la medicina
al servicio de terminar una vida
entonces ahí es donde nace en una de
estos dilemas pero yo quiere terminar
con esa reflexión de al final que
significa terminar con una vida si lo
que termina con una vida no puede ser
por ejemplo ya una enfermedad
incapacitante o un dolor insoportable si
no es ahí en ese momento en el que se
termina la vida y se habla al final
hablar de cómo morir también es hablar
de cómo vivir de cómo queremos vivir
dignamente y pasar este último tiempo es
quemar cien por ciento una persona
vegetal digamos después ya se le terminó
la vida alguna manera pues y ahí al
final también por supuesto entran ahora
que además hay muchos países que están
teniendo estos debates sobre cómo
legislar eso pues que todos los
consentimientos sean muy informados que
las vidas sean dignas para no caer en
esos problemas de desigualdades sociales
que estábamos hablando y también en que
las legislaciones sean claras para que
todas las personas sepan con qué reglas
están jugando un debate apasionante
marco vamos a estar aquí horas
sobre este tema y poner pues nuestras
ideas en la mesa pero lamentablemente la
tengo que despedir gracias por toda esta
información nos vemos la próxima semana
en más de salud de directo américa tarde
a raúl